hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'm going to talk a bit more about
the ninjatrader volume metric footprint
chart and a little bit about uh you know
one of their order flow tools that they
have there now before we jump in if you
enjoy these videos be sure to subscribe
to the channel click the notification
Bell so you don't miss any new upload
and if you find today's video helpful uh
be sure to hit the like button for me
and leave a comment sharing your biggest
takeaway you know I love hearing your
feedback actually this video is uh the
result of a comment from a user
um commenting on kind of an oversight
that I did on the footprint chart you
know I was sort of knocking the
volumetric
chart from Ninja caters sorry ninja
Trader sorry I get those two mixed up
quite a bit
um because I was saying you know there's
no way to see the let me get a
crosshairs on here
um no way to see the point of control
on the chart okay because you know I'm
so used to looking at a footprint and
seeing you know basically a box around
the point of control right which is the
the price level with the most volume in
the bar okay and on the volumetric chart
where I sort of got uh I was like I
guess confused or overlooked is you know
I'm looking at the show maximum right if
you have show maximum enabled okay right
it's enabled it will highlight it as
yellow it'll highlight the volumes as
yellow in the footprint and you know
that's going to be a problem if you have
an imbalance or something else that you
want to look at
and
actually what uh
this gracious user can't prevent Seth
you know credit to you he said hit the
show volume in the data series for God's
sakes man and if you do that let me just
get it up here it will actually print a
profile next to the bar so you got to
scroll down in here
show where is it show volume right here
so under chart Style it's about one you
know volumetric blah blah blah you get
down to show volume about the one two
three four five six choice
and it's going to
put the little volume profile on the
side of the bar and the yellow
level
is the point of control in that bar okay
so you know that's a way to do it but do
keep in mind
if you do not
so used to looking at under an indicator
not the data series if you have the uh
for any reason I don't know why you
would not have it on not enable it but
if you hit disable show maximum
right it's not going to print
the maximum value the maximum volume in
the bar right the point of control
um as yellow okay is this going to be
your normal color of the volume in the
footprint it's going to be your normal
sort of little volume profile on the
side of the bar then you'd have to sort
of you know guess is this one more than
this one but again shout out to uh our
user camper van Seth
by saying uh hit the show volume button
here
and
you gotta have the maximum on there
where is it here it is show maximum
and again you can change the color to
whatever color you want default is
yellow okay
so there you go thanks again anyway
that's why I say you know guys be sure
to uh you know put your comments below
because again I use my own order flow
Trader software
um I'm I don't you even though I have
the paid version of ninja
Trader I don't use their volumetric
chart now there is some useful things in
the paid version of ninja Trader right
the fully paid version
um in their order flow Suite so what you
can do is you scroll down
yeah and you have cumulative Delta
Market depth you know trade detector
order flow volume profile and Order flow
view app okay now again I don't use the
market I don't use any of these actually
but the market depth as far as I know
again you know if I'm wrong just mention
it in the comment I believe you do have
it's one of those tools where you have
to have the software running I don't
know if it really works on the
historical data well let's try it out
let me just open a brand new chart here
to the best of my knowledge okay and
again I'm not a regular user of
the market depth map here but we'll just
put up a one minute make that tick
replay hit Okay
um
then I'm going to add
you know again you know if some of you
guys use this and
foreign
you can do it with historical depth
let me know because uh you know I did
have a few users asking about it
I don't see it on there maybe you'd have
to run it and pick replay but as far as
um you know opening up a chart
and having it appear on there I believe
you'd have to it will start plotting the
depth from the time that you open your
chart okay and again maybe if you're
running it in
Market replay to watch the depth you
know after the Market's close you can do
that but uh you know the other tool that
I want to talk about
that they have on here which is which is
useful for a lot of Traders and
it is called let me just take this one
off
the cumulative Delta okay now what
that's going to do
right it's going to plot
at the bottom of your chart
you know the the delta
in a Candlestick form okay now this is
the cumulative Delta so it's showing you
out you know throughout the day
um you know
either there's going to be a zero line
somewhere up here I wish they would draw
a zero line maybe again you know as far
as I know I don't know if they have a
function in the setting to draw the zero
line I haven't seen it but um you got
two choices session Delta which would be
basically your cumulative Delta or on a
bar by bar basis
okay now
this is how it looks on a bar by bar
basis okay and there's certain patterns
in here you know I talked about the
Delta reversal
um and you know sort of opportunities
like that and
what you could do
sometimes people think oh I can only
have one or the other
is you should be able to add another one
you just click on it again here so you
see it down here so say I want the
session and the bar
right you're going to click on a new
panel
so you're going to have both
okay and again it's a simple thing
sometimes you know people are a little
confused on oh I can't I can only have
one or there no you could have two you
just gotta when you add it
under the indicator setting just make
sure panel because now it says two for
and three right the main chart up here
is panel right so this is panel one this
is panel two this is panel three okay
one two three now
when you add
it just make sure you hit well you're
going to have a choice I believe it says
new panel
on there it'll just go down
right new panel right you see it there
but that way
you know you could have both a bar by
bar basis of Delta
and cumulative Delta okay now I'm not
going to get into
the you know there's a lot of patterns
you can see in cumulative Delta there's
a lot of patterns you can see in bar by
bar Delta and it's quite uh you know
it's quite interesting you know it's
it was like for example that's uh just
expand this up because you know I've
been making some videos on Delta
recently you know it's funny people say
well you don't treat strategies you know
you just show people what happened well
yeah I'm showing you what happened so
you can build your own strategy by
taking what happens in the market it's
not about me saying this is how you're
supposed to trade
and that's it no you know like for
example here
on the cumulative Delta you see Delta
going down down down down and then
starts turning going up whereas on a bar
by bar Delta even though Delta you know
is still negative it's actually going up
right in the sense that it's strong
a little less strong a little less
strong than obviously positive on here
you sort of seeing the same thing
going on in terms of the candle size but
it's getting weaker as it's going down
into this low as opposed to you know low
earth you get the strong Delta here
right remember over here you got this
big
Delta big negative Delta coming in here
so there are patterns that you can see
either on a bar by bar basis like this
that I like to look for or even in the
cumulative Delta itself right I know
people like to look for divergences in
the cumulative Delta
um I know people like to look for Delta
you know divergences in the bar by bar
Delta I did get a few questions a few
comments from users asking to make some
videos on
Delta Divergence and you know honestly
there's there's for me when I talk about
Delta Divergence I talk about a new or
equal low with positive Delta or a new e
or equal high with negative Delta and
some people
some Traders
see Delta Divergence on a bar by bar
basis so when I'm looking at it is you
know add new highs or new lows whereas
some Traders will look at it on a bar by
bar basis and you know for example
you know here right you got a green
candle with
negative Delta
right green candle with negative Delta
technically this is a bar this is a bar
Delta Divergence right because normally
on a green candle you're going to have
positive Delta
right not negative Delta but there's a
reason why you have that right there is
some absorption going on in there
because you have a strong passive bid in
the market right which is which if you
know if you have a strong passive bid in
the market to absorb whatever aggressive
selling is taking place in that bar it's
going to be bullish
okay so I guess there's three types of
Delta Divergence there's there's at the
highs or lows there's on a bar by bar
basis and there's even within the
cumulative Delta intraday
um you're going to see
you know divergences take place
in the Deltas right I mean people say
well here's
you know
we've got price going lower but is Delta
going lower yeah I guess so here but
what about here this one's probably
lower prices but anyway you get the gist
of it
um
you know so there's a lot of ways you
could use Delta in your trading
um don't don't think that just because I
I say I talk about one way to use Delta
that that's the only way Delta is you
know basically what Delta is it's data
right and
what makes Delta unique is it's not
dependent on price movement it's
dependent on aggressive trading that's
taking place
so it gives you a sort of an extra
insight into what's taking place you
know in the market all right so
anytime you could have
insight into the market that maybe not a
lot of other Traders have you think
that's going to give you an edge I think
it does you know we could argue that it
does that it doesn't it's irrelevant
it's just the same as you know I worked
at commodity trading firms and
you know we have the data that nobody
else has right I worked at Cargill we
know basically how much corn is planted
in areas because you know we're on the
ground talking to the farmers that gives
you know some of these commodity trading
firms an edge over regular traders that
don't have access to that that are
relying on the government data so you
know anytime you can have access to data
that maybe not a lot of people have
because again not a lot of people use
order flow and look at the delta
then in my opinion it's just going to
give you an advantage over other Traders
but anyway I mean that's what makes the
market right is differences of opinions
so anyway guys if you've enjoyed this
video I'm going to wrap it up and I'll
see you guys on the next video be sure
to leave your comments again you know
shout out to the guy uh what was his
name camper van Seth you know thanks for
pointing that out you know again it's I
don't use that volumetric chart but if
you do that's how you would get the
um
Point control okay
thanks everyone bye-bye